[Applaudissements]
qui va franchement avec moi tu te gêne
pas vincent est ce que tu as été content
d'être avec nous moi je t'avoue qu'à la
base je voulais ouest à buca là bas je
voulais recevoir sébastien chabal c'est
vrai ouais aussi je voudrais aller au
grand journal mais bon alors vas
champagne-mouton spectacle à la con
c'est bien le cas de lurs un spectacle à
la cause parle énormément de poids iem
passage à une équipe de bras cassés
je prends le toit et c'est ce que tu
manifestes par le post est dans une
position bois de boulogne
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ce chien galeux là il m'a pas mine quand
il me l'a dit là bas je parle de toi
dans ce spectacle je m'attendais à un
truc ça bah ouais tu es donc est doté au
bois de boulogne
c'est en ce sens que tu veux toi je te
connais c'est bon alors tu joues le soir
de la saint valentin c'est parce que
t'as pas de bond est ce que tu veux te
sentir moins seul c'est vrai que j'ai
passé un moment ça et me sert pas la
fontaine
alors tu as fait une publicité pour du
cantal on doit avec des vaches ça t'as
fait quoi de tourner avec des animaux
qui jouent mieux la comédie que toi ça
sera pas facile quand tu as un mouchoir
rouge de me reposer la même question
en plus elle a vraiment je le dis tout
ça super comédien vincent vraiment mais
je sais pas comment tu fais chaque poste
que moi jouer dit il joue bien ce qu'on
a mais ça va c'est ce qui m'est avis ils
sont bien ils jouent bien pensante a
fait une carrière de rugbyman pourquoi
avoir choisi un sport de combat est vu
comme une thèse cyril club qu'est ce
qu'un homme était épais comme un pic à
bigorneaux d'avion il m'a vu en slip en
plus ça on est à 1 on a passé à l'ombre
ça s'est joué à vous le dire on a passé
un long moment si ce n'est pas la fin
j'ai patrick sébastien c'était dans la
lente en tout les jours que les gens des
vrais kabyle va coller alors pour finir
je tiens à féliciter pour ta carrière
vraiment vincent elle est vraiment
magnifique parce que franchement avec ta
gueule ce n'est pas gagné car j'aimerais
savoir
merci de me parler d'abord de ma
carrière parce que c'est très gentil de
tapas et la tienne et commence quand
[Applaudissements]